THAT IS THE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW TO REACT,
NEWT GINGRICH, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AND HOST OF THE NEW
PODCAST.
YOU AND I HAVE BEEN, RUNNING
AROUND WASHINGTON FOR A LONG
TIME WATCHING THESE DEBATES AND
SO FORTH, WHY ARE THE DEMOCRATS
CONTINUING TO HAVE THIS BLIND
SPOT ON WHERE MANY IN THE MIDDLE
RESIDE ON ISSUES SUCH AS THE
ISSUE OF LIFE?
>> I THINK THE TRUE FAITH OF THE
LEFT DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS NOW IN
FULL BLOSSOM, I THINK THEY GET
TOGETHER IN MEETINGS AND TALK TO
EACH OTHER AND WALK TO
FUND-RAISERS WITH PEOPLE WHO
AGREED WITH THEM AND CONVINCE
THEMSELVES FOR EXAMPLE AS HE
POINTED OUT IF YOU HAD EVER SAID
TO ME TEN YEARS AGO, WE WOULD BE
APPROVING INFANTICIDE AND AS YOU
POINT OUT, THE NEW YORK
LEGISLATION WOULD BE APPLAUDING
AND CHEERING THAT THEY PASS THE
RIGHT TO KILL BABIES AFTER THEY
ARE BORN.
THIS IS GROTESQUE.
MOST AMERICANS DON'T AGREE WITH
IT.
AMONG THE HARD-CORE LEFT ON
ISSUE AFTER ISSUE AFTER ISSUE,
THEY BELIEVE THINGS THAT I THINK
PERSONALLY ARE CRAZY.
I DON'T THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WILL ENDORSE AND I THINK
IT MAY SET UP A 1972 DISASTER
WHERE THEY END UP SO FAR ON THE
LEFT WING LIMB THAT PEOPLE
DECIDE THEY CAN'T VOTE FOR THEM.
>> Laura: GOING BACK TO THE
EQUAL RIGHTS AMENDMENT, SHE
SUCCESSFULLY LED THE EFFORT TO
KILL THE ERA.
I REMEMBER READING ABOUT HOW THE
DEMOCRATS BACK THEN THOUGHT, WE
GOT THEM NOW.
WE WILL VANQUISH THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY FOREVER AND WHAT HAPPENED,
RONALD REAGAN WAS ELECTED.
THEY BEEN HEADING THE SAME DRUM
FOR DECADES ABOUT THE SOCIAL
ISSUES, BUT THEY DON'T GO AWAY
AND THE DEMOCRATS JUST KEEP
MOVING FURTHER AND FURTHER TO
THE LEFT.
>> I WAS IN CALIFORNIA OVER THE
WEEKEND TALKING TO PEOPLE AND
THE NUMBER OF WOMEN WHO CAME UP
TO ME AND SAID THEY ARE WORRIED
BECAUSE THEY THINK THEIR
DAUGHTERS ARE NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE A SUCCESSFUL
WOMEN'S SPORTS PROGRAM BECAUSE
OF THE DRIVE OF THE DEMOCRATS TO
BASICALLY ALLOW TRANSGENDERED
MALES TO DOMINATE WOMEN SPORTS.
I DON'T THINK PEOPLE HAVE
REALIZED WHAT AN ASSAULT OF THIS
IS GOING TO BE ON WOMAN AND ON
RIGHT TO COMPETE.
THAT IS THE SORT OF THING, YOU
WILL NOT GET "VOGUE" MAGAZINE TO
PRINT AND YOU WILL KNOCK AT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" TO PRINT
AND THAT IS WHAT IT TAKES A
WHILE.
THE COUNTRY GRADUALLY RECOILS
AFTER THE LEFT-WING
ESTABLISHMENT HAS DONE ALL ITS
COULD AND I THINK YOU'LL SEE
THAT RECOIL ON EIGHT OR TEN
ISSUES THIS COMING YEAR.
>> Laura: YOU CAN PICTURE HIM
LOOKING AT HIS OPPONENT AND
SAYING, YOU ARE A PARTY PASSED
LEGISLATION IN THE HOUSE THAT
WOULD COMPEL GIRLS AND A
LOCKER ROOM TO WELCOME A
BIOLOGICAL MALE IN THE
LOCKER ROOM WHILE THEY'RE
GETTING READY FOR THEIR SPORTS
OR LEAVING THE LOCKER ROOM.
THAT WOULD BE COMPELLED BY
FEDERAL LAW.
TRUMP IS NEVER GOING TO LET THAT
WEASEL OUT OF THIS.
YOU WANT BOYS TO SHOWER THE SAME
LOCKER ROOM AS GIRLS BECAUSE
THAT IS WHAT THE LEGISLATION
MANDATES.
THEY WILL HAVE TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION.
>> IN CONNECTICUT TWO
TRANSGENDERED MALES WON HE
WOMEN'S SPORTS EVENT.
LET'S BE CLEAR ABOUT THIS, THIS
IS THE MOST BIZARRE REVERSAL OF
ALL THE PRINCIPLES OF THE 50
YEAR FIGHT FOR WOMEN'S RIGHTS.
>> Laura: WHERE THE FEMINISTS?
>> A TRANSGENDER MALE SOCCER
TEAM, IT'S CRAZY IN TERMS OF
WHAT DOES THIS DO TO WOMEN'S
RIGHTS TO BE ABLE TO COMPETE AND
TO BE ABLE TO BE INVOLVED IN AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THEY HAVE A
REASONABLE CHANCE TO WIN?
>> Laura: THEY ARE SO TWISTED
IN KNOTS AND RADICALISM I DON'T
THINK THEY KNOW HOW TO UNKNOT TO
THEMSELVES.
BY THE WAY, THIS WAS THE MAYOR
PETE BUTTIGIEG AT THE SUPREME
COURT RALLY TODAY ON ABORTION.
>> THIS IS ONE MORE EXAMPLE OF A
MOMENT WHERE THE MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS AGREE ON SOMETHING AND
THERE IS A LOT OF EXTREMISM OF
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY THAT IS
FORCING MODERATES TO ASK WHETHER
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS LEFT
THEM BEHIND.
>> Laura: EXTREMISTS IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY?
REALLY?
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW TO EXPLAIN
TO THE MAYOR THAT THE
OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS, 81% ARE OPPOSED TO
KILLING BABIES AFTER THEY ARE
BORN.
THE POSITIONS HE IS TAKING ARE
VERY MINORITY POSITIONS.
I THINK AGAIN AND AGAIN, THE
SAME CONVERSATION GOING ON.
YOU'VE LEFT-WING DEMOCRATS GOING
TO LEFT-WING RALLIES TO GO AND
SAY LEFT-WING THINGS AND THEN TO
COMPETE, THE NEXT PERSON HAS TO
BE EVEN MORE EXTREME.
THAT IS WHY YOU HAVE $0.20
DEMOCRATS RUNNING WILDLY TO THE
LEFT.
>> Laura: KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND
IS ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS
BEEN TRYING TO REGAIN OR GAIN I
SHOULD SAY AT A TRACTION IN THIS
VERY CROWDED FIELD AND A LOT OF
PEOPLE THOUGHT AFTER THE ME TOO
MOVEMENT AND HARVEY WEINSTEIN
THAT SHE WOULD EMERGE FROM THE
PACK, BUT SHE IS ALSO
STRUGGLING.
SHE SAID THIS ABOUT THE ISSUE
NEAR AND DEAR TO YOUR HEART, THE
HEIGHT AMENDMENT.
>> WE HAVE A TENANT IN OUR
CONSTITUTION CALLED SEPARATION
OF CHURCH AND STATE AND I DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT THAT IS A VALID
ARGUMENT.
I THINK THAT AMENDMENT SHOULD BE
REPEALED.
>> Laura: TELL THE "THE
INGRAHAM ANGLE" AUDIENCE
HERETICAL THAT IS IF YOU WANT TO
REPEAL THAT.
>> THAT GOES BACK TO THE 1970s
AND IT'S INTERESTED TO MAKE A
SIMPLE STATEMENT, NO AMERICANS
SHOULD BE FORCED TO PAY TAXES TO
PAY FOR AN ABORTION.
IT'S BEEN CONSISTENT FOR 40
YEARS AND AGAIN, ARE THEY GOING
TO SAY, WE HAVE THE RIGHT TO
KILL A BABY AFTER ITS BORN, WE
HAVE THE RIGHT TO CHARGE THE
TAXPAYER WHILE WE ARE KILLING
THE BABY.
THINK ABOUT THIS STUFF.
A VERY RADICAL POSITION,
BERNIE SANDERS SAID HE DIDN'T
MIND IF THEY HAD SEX SELECTION
ABORTIONS.
IF YOU PERMIT THAT THERE WILL BE
FAR MORE FEMALES THAN MALES AND
THAT IS WHAT HE SAID HE WAS
WILLING TO ACCEPT.
THEY ARE CAUGHT IN A DOWNWARD
SPIRAL.
NOT ONLY ON THIS ISSUE BUT A
WHOLE RANGE OF ISSUES WHERE I
THINK THEY WILL BECOME HARDER
AND HARDER TO DEFEND.
>> Laura: WE PLAYED THE
SOUND BITE EARLIER DEMONSTRATING
HOW FAR LEFT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
BEEN.
I THINK OBAMA HAS ALWAYS BEEN
THERE, BUT THE PARTY HASN'T
ABSENT OR WHETHER IT'S ON THE
QUESTION OF GAY MARRIAGE OR THE
ISSUE OF ABORTION OR GENDER
BENDING.
YOU HAVE A SENSE THAT JOE BIDEN
IS NOT COMFORTABLE WITH ANY OF
THIS.
HE HAS TO BE LIKE, MY
CONSULTANTS ARE TELLING ME I
HAVE TO SAY THAT STUFF BUT I
STILL DO GO TO MASS ON SUNDAY.
I STOP TO FIGURE THIS OUT.
>> AS HE POINTED OUT
WHEN YOU SHOW THE SEGMENT OF
OBAMA LYING ABOUT HIS POSITION
ON MARRIAGE, HE WAS ALWAYS A
RADICAL WHO UNDERSTOOD HE
COULDN'T GET ELECTED SO WHEN THE
CLASSIC TRADITION HE PRETENDED
TO BE MODERATE LONG ENOUGH TO
GET ELECTED.
THE THING TO REMEMBER ABOUT
JOE BIDEN AND I HAVE KNOWN HIM
FOR A LONG TIME, HE IS SO
SHALLOW THAT HE WON'T NOTICE
MOST OF THIS.
HE WILL THINK IT'S KIND OF
CONFUSING.
HE WILL DRIFT ALONG BEING
JOE BIDEN.
IF HE COULD GET NOMINATED IT
WILL BE BY BEING THIS NICE
PLEASANT DOOFUS WHO DOESN'T KNOW
ANYTHING, THAT IS WHAT HE IS
COUNTING ON IS BEING THE LEAST
DISGUSTING PERSON IN THE FIELD.
>> Laura: THE OTHER ISSUE WE
TOUCHED ON LAST NIGHT WAS THIS
MOVE AGAINST THE FOUNDERS.
THIS HAS BEEN BUBBLING FOR SOME
TIME, POINT OUT STATUTES AND SO
FORTH.
EVERYONE FEELS BETTER WHEN YOU
PULLED ON A ROBERT E. LEE STATU
STATUE.
NOW OF COURSE AS PREDICTED
MOVING AGAINST THOMAS JEFFERSON,
THE AUTHOR OF THE DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE.
BUTTIGIEG THINKS HE CAN RENAME
THAT.
WHY WOULD YOU RENAME SCHOOLS,
BOULEVARDS, AND ULTIMATELY TAKE
DOWN THE STATUES?
>> ONE OF THE THINGS I HAVE
CONCLUDED THAT THESE PEOPLE ARE
SO RADICAL WE HAVE TO TAKE THEM
HEAD-ON.
THIS IS LEFT-WING FASCIST
TOTALITARIANISM.
THIS IS AN EFFORT TO INCREASE
THE MEMORY OF THE UNITED STATES.
THOMAS JEFFERSON AS A FACT.
HE WROTE THE DECLARATION OF
INDEPENDENCE AND HE CREATED THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IRONICALLY IN
TERMS OF PEOPLE WHO WANT TO
BESMIRCH THEM.
HE WAS EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT
IN THE DEVELOPMENT OF AMERICA,
BUT WHAT YOU HAVE AS A GROUP OF
LEFT-WING DEMOCRATS WOULD LIKE
TO ERASE ALL OF OUR MEMORIES OF
AMERICA.
THEY REALLY DIVE DEEP WANT US TO
BE LIKE VENEZUELA AND IT'S
REMARKABLE AND I THINK WE HAVE
THE CONSERVATIVE SIDE HAVE TO BE
MUCH TOUGHER WITH TAKING THEM
HEAD-ON.
IT'S EXACTLY LIKE THE TALIBAN
DESTROYING THE TWO BUDDHIST
STATUES THAT WERE HISTORIC
WORLDWIDE MONUMENTS.
PETE IS EXACTLY LIKE OBAMA.
HE PRETENDS TO BE A MODERATE
UNTIL YOU LISTEN TO THEM AND
REALIZE HE IS AS RADICAL AS
ANYBODY ELSE.
>> Laura: AND EXTREMIST WITH A
MODERATE EXTERIOR OR A
MILD-MANNERED EXTERIOR.